[Aplausos]
[Música]
en 1980 al histórico líder del cartel de
medellín pablo escobar gaviria se le
encendió la bombilla por así decirlo
tuvo una visión un sueño convertir a
colombia en un narcoestado un país donde
el propio gobierno y las propias
instituciones públicas estuvieran
dirigidas y controladas directamente por
el narcotráfico tal fue su empeño que en
1982 como creo que todos sabéis el mismo
el propio pablo escobar uno de los
mafiosos más importantes de toda la
historia terminó sentándose en la cámara
de representantes de la república de
colombia
y amigos no perdamos de vista una
cuestión una cosa es que la mafia compre
y soborno a un político y otra muy
distinta es que ellos mismos controlen
el poder os imaginais un país donde la
policía el ejército los funcionarios de
la administración y de hasta los propios
tribunales estuvieran en última
instancia bajo las órdenes directas de
los narcos desde luego amigos de haberse
llevado a cabo la visión de pablo
escobar colombiano sólo habría
multiplicado sus niveles de producción y
exportación de narcóticos sino que el
propio cartel de medellín hubiera sido
intocable invencible hubiera logrado la
total impunidad para hacer y deshacer a
su antojo
por fortuna pablo escobar gaviria nunca
consiguió llevar a cabo su sueño sin
embargo hoy tres décadas después parece
que su sueño ahora sí se está llevando a
cabo claro que en esta ocasión no
hablamos de colombia sino de venezuela
hay que decirlo con un hashtag colombia
produce la cocaína de este mundo y eso
debe acabarse nosotros si lo capturamos
aquí hemos capturado más de 100 capos
de la droga colombiana aquí en venezuela
somos víctimas y así nos declaramos
según parece estos cuatro personajes que
estáis viendo no sólo tienen el control
del país sino que además son los líderes
de toda una red internacional del crimen
y el narcotráfico hablamos por supuesto
de nicolás maduró presidente de
venezuela del poderoso presidente de la
asamblea nacional constituyente diosdado
cabello al que muchos ya sitúan como el
hombre más fuerte del régimen de tarek
el aissami ex vicepresidente y actual
ministro de industria y producción
nacional cuya fortuna personal según los
cálculos de la dea supera ojo los tres
mil millones de dólares
y el cuarto en estos reverol ministros
de relaciones interiores justicia y paz
que para colmo fue el anterior director
de la oficina nacional antinarcóticos
pues bien amigos todo apunta a que estas
cuatro personas están liderando la
transformación de venezuela en todo un
narcoestado atentos
[Música]
la mafia toma el control venezuela está
en la ruina el hambre está creciendo la
inflación está descontrolada y cientos
de miles de personas están huyendo ya ni
siquiera los hospitales tienen
suministros básicos como medicinas
equipos de análisis o tiritas amigos el
desastre es tan grande que la propia
pedevesa la empresa nacional de
petróleos del país con más reservas del
mundo está en quiebra
fijaos a día de hoy pedevesa tiene
tantas órdenes de embargo que para poder
vender el cada vez más menguante
petróleo venezolano está empezando a
recurrir a trucos y técnicas propias de
los contrabandistas de las películas de
hollywood aquí un ejemplo
fijaos como los petroleros venezolanos
tienen riesgo de ser confiscados para
saldar las deudas pendientes con el
petróleo que transportan pedevesa ha
empezado a transferir en altamar el
petróleo desde sus barcos a otros barcos
con bandera cubana que luego se encargan
de llevar el crudo a su destino evitando
así que sea embargado
[Música]
y es que amigos en venezuela
prácticamente todo lo que tiene valor ha
sido o está siendo saqueado la
corrupción ha llegado a casi todos los
rincones del país vamos a ver la
revolución bolivariana da prometió
prosperidad lo que se olvidaron de
matizar es que toda esa prosperidad iba
a ser sólo para unos pocos para los
amigos de la revolución claro no me
creéis pues fijaos muchos miembros del
régimen han promovido y lideran el
contrabando con gasolina para venderla
en brasil y en colombia son los máximos
responsables del contrabando con
alimentos y medicinas comprados por el
estado y vendidos luego en el mercado
negro han saqueado las cuentas públicas
y han desaparecido decenas de miles de
millones de dólares tanto del gobierno
como de pedevesa
bueno es que en venezuela se han
saqueado incluso los dólares del banco
central sí sí tal cual como lo escucháis
veréis me explicó una de las primeras
cosas que hizo el régimen chavista fue
implantar un rígido control de cambios
que fijaba por ejemplo un cambio oficial
entre el bolívar y el dólar
estadounidense un tipo de cambio que no
tenían nada que ver con la cotización en
la calle de esta forma los amiguetes del
gobierno han podido acceder a dólares
estadounidenses entregando apenas un
puñado de bolívares el chollo era tal
que se estima que el 20 por ciento de
todas las importaciones declaradas eran
operaciones completamente falsas que se
realizaban con el único propósito de
conseguir dólares al cambio oficial
dólares que luego se guardaban en
cuentas en el extranjero y ojo porque
según las estimaciones podemos estar
hablando de un robo de más de 100 mil
millones de dólares
y por supuesto pedevesa no se ha librado
de este expolio un grupo de empresas
prestaron a pedevesa 7200 millones de
bolívares que cambiados al precio del
mercado negro serían el equivalente a
casi 42 millones de dólares pero al ser
cambiados a tasa oficial eso se
convirtió en aproximadamente 600
millones de dólares que fueron
depositados en una cuenta en malta césar
para ti periodista venezolano pero claro
como el país ya no da más de sí los
gerifaltes del régimen se han buscado
una nueva fuente de ingresos atentos es
propio de los propios de acuerdo ya que
el edificio allá en la esquina ahora ven
dámelo al gobierno al estado entonces
ahora los dueños dicen no no queremos
vender ahora yo digo no yo se los compro
cuánto vale que se lo pagamos y vamos a
recuperar el banco de venezuela para
ponerlo al servicio de los venezolanos
no está en venta pero que sabe que yo lo
puedo expropiar perfectamente
lo puedo propio
los modelos productivos que hasta ahora
hemos ensayado ha fracasado y la
responsabilidad es nuestra es mía es
tuya somos nosotros glorita lo están
ratificando aquí ellos mismos se salve
está ratificando
la conversión en un narcoestado
el tema de los narcos y venezuela no es
algo nuevo lo que ocurre es que por así
decirlo ha evolucionado veréis me
explico durante muchos años los carteles
colombianos trataron de utilizar rutas a
través de venezuela para distribuir sus
productos y claro para lograrlo pues
digamos que empezaron a sobornar a
policías a miembros de la guardia
nacional
altos funcionarios etcétera etcétera
para que hicieran la vista gorda esta
fue la primera etapa como la cosa
funcionaba los narcos conocían cada vez
mejor el terreno y sabían de quién
podían o no podían fiarse pues se pasó a
una segunda etapa algo así como oye ya
puestos si te doy más dinero ya no solo
miras para otro lado también proteges y
te encargas de transportar mi mercancía
esta fue la segunda etapa luego muchos
mafiosos colombianos se tiene en cuenta
que ante la enorme presión que tenían
del gobierno colombiano y de la dea
estaría más seguros en venezuela así que
a partir de principios del siglo 21 eso
es precisamente lo que pasó que muchos
de estos siniestros comerciantes
trasladaron su centro de operaciones
desde colombia a venezuela y hay ya la
colaboración con las autoridades empezó
a ser muy pero que muy estrecha creo que
decir estrechas es quedarse cortos que
pensáis que hizo entonces el gobierno de
venezuela pues decidió ni más ni menos
en 2005 expulsar del territorio
venezolano a la dea y además suspender
el acuerdo para monitorear los narco
vuelos de esta forma el territorio
venezolano se convirtió en una especie
de refugio para los barcos los eeuu ya
no podían seguirles la pista que
fantástico no eso sí a cambio de
librarse de los gringos tenían que pagar
una modesta comisión de algo tendrían
que vivir los gerifaltes del régimen no
esta fue la tercera etapa pero espera de
un momento amigos porque así es como
llegamos a la cuarta y última etapa que
es en la que nos encontramos ahora mismo
el negocio iba viento en popa también
que muchos de los gerifaltes de la
revolución bolivariana se hicieron una
pregunta tenemos al gobierno a la
policía al ejército y un montón de
recursos por qué diantres tenemos que
compartir nada con los colombianos o con
quien sea nosotros y lo capturamos aquí
hemos capturado más de 100 capos de la
droga colombiana aquí en venezuela
sabéis qué pasó entonces pues que las
autoridades venezolanas empezaron a
detener a todos los narcos que no
querían cooperar entregándole su ruta sí
y su negocio de distribución así es cómo
cayeron personajes de la talla de
maximiliano bonilla alias 'valenciano'
jefe de la oficina de envigado
héctor germán buitrago alias martín
llanos diego pérez henao alias diego
rastrojo o daniel barrera barrera alias
'el loco' todos ellos con sitio propio
en la lista de los traficantes más
importantes
de esta forma todo apunta a que ahora
mismo en venezuela aunque existen un
montón de grupos operando en el terreno
los colectivos los planes los
paramilitares lln los disidentes de las
farc las mega bandas en última instancia
el control lo obtienen los gerifaltes
del gobierno personajes como diosdado
cabello presuntamente el jefe más
importante del cartel de los soles que
es como se conoce al cartel formado por
los altos mandos del gobierno
bolivariano el pueblo venezolano sufre
bajo políticos corruptos que se agarran
al poder mientras se llenan los
bolsillos estamos fijando sanciones
contra personajes como diosdado cabello
que explotan su posición en el gobierno
para involucrarse en el narcotráfico
blanqueo de dinero malversación de
fondos públicos y otras actividades de
corrupción
steve mano sin secretario del tesoro de
los eeuu de hecho uno de los asistentes
personales del mismísimo diosdado
cabello leas mi salazar huyó de
venezuela en 2014 con ayuda de la dea y
su declaración no pudo ser más
contundente además de aportar evidencias
sobre el funcionamiento de la
organización declaró que el señor
diosdado cabello presidente de la
asamblea nacional constituyente da
directamente órdenes sobre las rutas y
la salida de lanchas cargadas con
sustancias prohibidas y no es el único
los testimonios acumulan en los
despachos de la dea ahí está por ejemplo
la declaración de walid makled cuando
fue detenido en colombia en 2011
makled fue uno de los narcos más
importantes de venezuela controlaba por
ejemplo puerto cabello que según la bea
era la puerta de salida para la mayor
parte de los narcóticos distribuidores
de este país pues bien atentos tras su
detención
makled declaró con todo lujo de detalles
que tenía sueldo a varias decenas de
generales venezolanos así como altos
funcionarios del gobierno como por
ejemplo henry rangel silva que más tarde
fue nombrado ministro de defensa o hugo
carvajal ex director de inteligencia del
ejército al que supuestamente le pagaba
50 mil dólares semanales menudo pedazo
de sueldo también declaró haber
financiado a una de las campañas de hugo
chávez a cambio de concesiones en puerto
cabello
con todas estas relaciones es fácil
entender como en noviembre de 2016
efraín antonio campos flores y francisco
flores de freitas dos sobrinos de la
misma cilia flórez la esposa de maduro
la primera dama venezolana fueron
condenados en un tribunal de nueva york
por conspirar para traficar con cientos
de kilos de narcóticos y es que amigos
según las estimaciones existentes
el negocio venezuela no para de crecer a
través de este país pasa ya entre el 15
y el 20 por ciento de toda la coca que
se mueve en el mundo cada año y no sólo
eso
al parecer el número de laboratorios
está multiplicando como la espuma claro
por un lado los gerifaltes de la
revolución bolivariana necesitan dinero
para mantener leales a las estructuras
de represión al ejército a la policía a
la guardia nacional además a cambio de
poder trabajar en venezuela las bandas
los colectivos los grupos mafiosos y
hasta lln le brindan su apoyo al régimen
y por supuesto como al negocio es
redondo madure compañías se siguen
llenando los bolsillos desgraciadamente
las consecuencias de todo esto son
terrible
e
por un lado el saqueo de todos los
recursos públicos ha llevado el país a
la ruina por otro lado está alimentando
una enorme violencia fijaos según datos
del observatorio venezolano de violencia
en 2017 en este país hubo 89 89
homicidios por cada 100.000 habitantes
es decir más de 26 mil personas
perdieron la vida de forma violenta
[Música]
venezuela se ha convertido en el país
más peligroso de toda américa latina y
la situación en algunas zonas como
caracas es aún peor la tasa de
homicidios en la capital se disparó el
año pasado a 130 personas por cada
100.000 habitantes mientras tanto los
miembros del gobierno que se están
aprovechando de esta situación y están
haciendo auténticas fortunas están
comprando propiedades por todo el mundo
desde la república dominicana donde
están promoviendo inversiones
millonarias en hoteles urbanizaciones
campos de golf hasta madrid una ciudad a
la que están llegando no sólo miles de
venezolanos que huyen de el desastre
sino también muchos familiares de todos
estos capos del cartel de los soles o de
altos cargos leales a la revolución
ahora me encuentro a veces sentado en
restaurantes de madrid justo al lado de
personas con las que no estaría cómodo
ni siquiera viendo las en caracas
leopoldo lopez jil padre de leopoldo
lópez la opositora venezolano bajo
arresto domiciliario en caracas
desgraciadamente amigos el régimen
bolivariano parece haber encontrado en
el narco a su mejor aliado tanto para
llenarse el bolsillo como para
mantenerse en el poder en fin amigos así
están las cosas
si eso ha resultado interesante el vídeo
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
al canal un saludo y hasta la próxima
somos un troglodita lo están ratificando
aquí de ellos mismos eso lo está
ratificando y vamos a recuperar el banco
de venezuela para ponerlo al servicio de
los venezolanos no está en venta pero
pero sabe que yo juego es propiedad
perfectamente lo puedo apropiar
[Aplausos]